over the next three days the team sticks
to a strategy
finally they are proven right but in the
worst way
y'all heard the other day that we had an
upstanding young lady from this
community was abducted about four thirty
by knifepoint by escapee Johnny Mac
Brown he forced her to take him to a
place in Franklin County more
importantly she is home safe we're
excited about that on day seven the
approaching line search drove Johnny
Mack Brown to rush into a nearby home
where he kidnapped a young woman and
forced her to drive him across the
perimeter it took this unfortunate
incident to prove that at least one of
the fugitives was laying low in the
containment zone all along the
particular escapee did show themself on
the last day of the last quadrant that
was searched
so in fact we were on target there
there were additional sightings of
Michael tweedle outside the perimeter
the first evidence that he too is no
longer in close range with both
fugitives gone it was time to break down
the perimeter and pass the search to the
u.s. marshals
they'll be safe appreciate Joe while he
did not get his men jacobs was confident
that his team forced the men to run and
in a manhunt a moving target is much
easier to catch once again his
experience proves correct community is
breathing a sigh of relief tonight as an
escaped prisoner is back behind bars
Johnny Mack Brown has been captured in
Livonia Georgia he was captured early
Saturday morning more than 150 miles
away from the Hays State Prison and
Tryon that he escaped from a month ago
about three weeks later three Livonia
police officers arrested Brown while he
was walking along a highway near Athens
Georgia he fought hard and even grabbed
for an officer's gun his officers had to
use night sticks pepper spray and even a
Taser to subdue Brown at first police
didn't recognize him
and had no idea the criminal they were
dealing with
he was taken straight to the Himax in
Jackson while in custody he was
uncooperative in helping the team locate
and recapture Michael tweedle